bonsoir vous retrouverez à 20h50 sur
france2 votre institut préférés vont
soir là
bonsoir l'histoire ce soir se déroulera
haute-savoie l'instit s'occupera d'un
élève
mathieu qui vit seule avec sa maman et
sa maman est au chômage c'est l'histoire
de nombreux enfants et de nombreuses
mamans c'est la chronique d'une
situation difficile pour certaines
familles situation que les dirigeants
politiques tentent d'améliorer valéry
giscard d'estaing est notre invité ce
soir il nous rejoindra dans un instant
il nous donnera son sentiment sur l'état
du pays est l'état de l'europe qui a
fait l'objet aujourd'hui d'un accord
entre le rpr et udf et qui est confronté
aux mêmes problèmes
ce problème a un nom l'angoissé sociale
qui aboutit parfois à la violence
elle a éclaté une fois encore dans une
banlieue près de paris
garges-les-gonesse à la suite de
l'assassinât une nouvelle fois d'un
jeune et de l'incompréhension entre les
policiers et les jeunes
anne mourgues et françois granier sont
sur place la boulangère a tenu à ouvrir
son magasin
malgré la devanture saccagé volonté
affichée de retour au calme comme la
plupart des habitants ici
elle veut oublier les scènes de la nuit
dernière ne plus jamais les voir se
reproduire dans la ville des événements
qui a occupé toute la soirée d'hier face
à face musclé entre jeunes et forces de
l'ordre voitures incendiées jets de
pierres vitrines brisées
ils veulent se venger du style car la
police selon eux à relâcher le meurtrier
présumé de leur ami tué lundi à la
courneuve il n'en démordront pas
comme ça rien et c'est parce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont relâché les aura la sienne
meurtrier le meurtrier a bien avoué aux
jeunes il avait avoué aux jeunes qu'il
était le meurtrier et ils l'ont relâché
commun les jeunes se tromper à ce moment
là
le meurtrier présumé est bien en garde à
vue entendu par les enquêteurs
plusieurs personnes le savent la police
bien sûr la justice certains élus ils
tenteront de le dire aux jeunes de leur
expliquer dialogue de sourds le maire
non plus n'a pas réussi ça m'est
difficile de pouvoir diffuser à travers
toute la ville un message de genre en
l'espace d'un quart d'heure ou d'une
demi heure de temps ils sont les
premiers touchés par cette affaire le
père et la soeur de l'adolescent a battu
ils sont aussi les premiers à appeler au
calme
fadi issu d'un côté
s'attaquer à la violence
voitures brûlées
gaza 6 jeudi
ce soir place de la mairie
la famille de la victime était là avec
plusieurs centaines d'habitants et le
soutien de nombreux élus ensemble pour
réclamer le retour au calme dans la cité
pour lutter contre le sentiment
d'exclusion le gouvernement veut offrir
un toit aux plus démunis il souhaite
ouvrir les portes de quarante mille
logements sociaux cette année à des
familles sans moyens des associations
relais seront mises à contribution
jantes pellieux jacques luigi ont suivi
l'une d'entre elles dans les yvelines un
ensemble de logements hlm neufs dans la
ville nouvelle de saint quentin
c'est ici qu'habitent roselyne depuis
quelques mois elle a obtenu sur le jouan
grâce à une association relais qui s'est
portée garante auprès du propriétaire la
fin d'une galère pour cette femme
célibataire et ses deux enfants ayant
quitté son compagnon elle avait demandé
à logements hlm en vain pendant des mois
fiche de paye en existe plein de choses
que je n'avais pas puisque je suis donc
travailleurs indépendants donc le
liévinois cette association vous a
fourni à l'appartement
c'est à dire qu'il peut payer pendant un
an et au bout d'un an s'il n'y a pas eu
de problème et ben il est à moi je serai
le côté au bout d'un an
roselyne fait partie des 700 ménages à
qui l'association a permis d'avoir le
logement social qu on leur refusait
jusque-là une action lancé il y a 6 ans
dans ce département pilote les résultats
pourtant inquiète les hlm hésitent à
signer le vrai bail avec des sous
locataires qui n'ont pas d'emploi stable
peu de départements d'autre part
s'engage à faire jouer ce système de
relais qui confrontait quand même à d un
pays extrêmement important n'accepte pas
d'emblée est directement des familles
qui qui sont quand même en difficulté
dont je pense qu'il faut augmenter les
associations et par ailleurs il faut
également je crois que les hlm assoupli
ses critères les départements surtout
l'état un peu finance ces associations
relais notamment par le biais des fonds
solidarité logement
le conseil des ministres a décidé
aujourd'hui une rallonge de 30 millions
pour ces fonds
une bonne nouvelle pour les démunis tu
cherches tu as toi mais la réponse à la
crise est aussi économique seule la
diminution du chômage permettra de
l'atténuer le gouvernement veut ainsi
attribuer le nouveau ces ipo c ap le
contrat d'insertion professionnelle aux
titulaires des c ap mais cela suscite
toujours l'hostilité de certains
syndicats qui voient dans cette mesure
le maintien d'un smic jeunes déguisés
pascal golomer le sait ip nouvelle
formule
edouard balladur on l'avait présentée
aux partenaires sociaux jeudi dernier à
matignon
il proposait de payer les jeunes
diplômés non plus à 80 % du smic mais à
80 % du salaire conventionnel c'est à
dire le salaire habituel prévues dans
chaque branche
pour chaque poste une concession par
rapport au premier texte
encore fallait-il précisé ce qu'on
entendait par jeunes diplômés le
ministre du travail a donc évoqué
aujourd'hui le sait ip nouvelle nouvelle
formule en plus des bac + 2 déjà prévu
dans les décrets les titulaires d'un bac
professionnel et même d'un ca paix
pourraient être considérés eux aussi
comme des diplômés seuls les non
diplômés se voit proposer un salaire en
dessous du smic pratique courante
d'ailleurs dans le traitement social du
chômage des jeunes au total la seule
nouveauté du ces ip c'est le tuteur
chargé au sein de l'entreprise de la
formation des jeunes notion encore à
définir
autant d'aménagements à négocier avec
des syndicats
toujours très mobilisés
je giraudi maintenant les diplômés ce
sera jusqu'au c ap bon très bien mais ça
veut quand même dire qu'il aura tout le
reste donc le problème smic-jeune
existantes or rencontre tant que tel
c'est la raison pour laquelle je crois
qu'il faut pas lâcher la pression
aujourd'hui un jeune à bac +2 ou ans et
ap à qui on dit vous allez avoir un
contrat d'insertion professionnelle va
se dit je vaux 80% d'un salaire et ça
c'est désespérant bravo edouard bonjour
le désespoir c'est pour ça qu on
manifestera nommant les étudiants demain
la cgt samedi fo et cfdt de 17 la sphère
du swing jeunes n'est pas encore une
affaire classée france télévisions
apporte sa contribution à la lutte
contre le chômage la chaîne de l'emploi
télé emploi mise au point par france
télévisions commencera le 28 mars sur le
cinquième réseau avant arte entre 7h du
matin et 19 heures si vous êtes un
collectionneur d'action et si vous
possédez déjà db npd rhône poulenc ou
des elfes vous pourrez désormais
enrichir votre portefeuille avec des agf
la compagnie d'assurances va être
privatisée au même titre que le groupe
informatique bull
vous espériez peut-être acheter des
renault la régie nationalisé par de
gaulle au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale n'est plus dans la liste des
privatisables
yannick letranchant privatisation suite
et pas encore fin le feuilleton continue
bull sera privatisée c'est officiel
quand mystère l'essentiel en fait est de
rassurer la commission de bruxelles
celle ci refuse que l'état français
verse à fonds perdus d aide à une
entreprise publique en promettant la
privatisation
le gouvernement compte faire passer en
douceur la rallonge qu'il apporte au
capital de bull exemple les 7 milliards
promis il y a quelques mois
il faut dire que bull est un malade
chronique sous perfusion sa
convalescence terminée
le groupe informatique sera donc
privatiser avec une formule différente
le capital ne sera pas vendu au public
mais à des entreprises du secteur où des
banques par exemple nous voulons faire
sortir bulle du giron de l'état
il faut que bull apprennent à voler de
ses propres ailes
telle est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons décidé de mettre bull sur le
décret de privatisation
pour le groupe automobile renault on
verra plus tard sa privatisation n'est
pas jugé indispensable pour le budget 94
arguments financiers dont ce n'est pas
le seul menace de conflit social
renault reste un symbole privatiser
renault être confrontés à des tensions
sociales importantes ça fera un problème
de plus qui amène le gouvernement à
réfléchir
privatiser renault pas maintenant
peut-être en 95 après les
présidentielles dit certain risque
social rimerait t-il avec risque
politique
cette actualité économique et social qui
alimente toutes les conversations
débouche souvent sur une seule et même
question lancinante la reprise
aura-t-elle lieu et à quel moment une
esquisse de réponse nous parvient de
genève
les constructeurs automobiles qui expose
semble relativement optimistes
relativement et le dise au milieu de
leurs nouvelles photos luke baziz alain
poirier astiquez dépoussiérer tout
doivent briller de tous leurs feux dans
moins de douze heures le public sera là
en vedette
ulysse chez fiat vision chez citroën ou
806 chez peugeot en fait le même
monospace avec seulement une différence
dans le regard
les constructeurs finisse et veulent
croire en la reprise nous sommes
véritablement complètement relancée en
février nous aurons présenté entre 12,8
et 13% du marché européen nous sont au
deuxième rang c'est à dire que peugeot
et ses droits avec des gab remarquables
sont bien partis pourtant le marché
avait chuté en france de plus de 18%
l'an dernier alors chacun une offre pour
séduire les volumes diminuent même
mercedes spécialiste des voitures
spacieuses fui la tendance fait pas
tellement l'homo ses emplettes chez
mercedes
première tranche fonctionnel volkswagen
avait été fait les prototypes en 1936
donc on a quand même un peu l'expérience
avec les petits droit pur les luxueuses
elle se donne des airs de fait la java
de bentley offre une allure plus
aérodynamique
al'approche de l'été d'autres se
découvre les décapotables se multiplient
et ne se ressemblent pas la suédoise
saab 900 la française 306 et la belle
américaine pontiac firebird fini les
gros 4 4
là aussi on raccourcit les modèles
toyota sur le fun cruiser pour aller
frimer sur les plages décidément ça sent
les vacances pas d'indicateurs
économiques sans indicateur politique le
nouveau béret à paris match révèle lui
aussi une baisse de la popularité
d'edouard balladur mais elle reste dans
le bv a au dessus de la barre des 50
thierry curtet la côte d'edouard
balladur continue de baisser à 53 % de
bonnes opinions le premier ministre perd
deux points
mais les bonnes opinions l'emportent
encore la courbe de françois mitterrand
elle se redresse avec 47% d'opinions
satisfaisante
elles progressent de 3% l'institut bbva
s'est livré à une étude d'image
d'edouard balladur ainsi 57% des sondés
estiment qu'il a la dimension d'un chef
d'état une image qui apparaît quelque
peu troublé par les récents événements
ainsi 51% estiment qu'il ne dit pas la
vérité aux français et 58% estiment
qu'il a tendance à vouloir les endormir
quand on les questionne sur les réformes
entreprises 56% trouve qu' edouard
balladur ne va pas assez loin
il trouve également à 53% qu'edouard
balladur a trop tendance à nommer ses
proches aux postes de responsabilité
dans les entreprises
avant de parler de l'europe avec notre
invité l'ancien président de la
république nous a rejoints bonsoir en
force car destin je voudrais vous donner
une un télégramme qui arrive à l'instant
de londres j'apprends à l'instant cinq
obus de mortier ont été tirés à
proximité de l'aéroport de heathrow près
de londres
c'est ce que vient d'annoncer le
ministre britannique de l'intérieur
il a précisé tout de même qu'il n'y
aurait pas de victime dont on peut être
d'autres informations sûrement au cours
de ce journal l'union l'union l'union
rimera anjou
avec l'europe l'europe l'europe le rpr
et l'udf ont adopté aujourd'hui
officiellement leur projet commun pour
la grande europe qui conduira la liste
unique de la majorité aux élections du 2
juin
en attendant de poser la question à
valéry giscard d'estaing écoutons
véronique sainte olive qui a suivi les
réunions oecuméniques et qui a lu le
texte à l'unanimité udf et rpr ont voté
oui pour le projet d'une europe nouvelle
pour siéger à strasbourg au sein d'un
même groupe démocrate chrétien pour
faire campagne avec une liste unique
alors ôté udf on se frotte les mains
le parlement européen il sera renforcé
avec un président élu pour cinq ans la
monnaie unique elle sera mise en place
avant 1999
tout cela à valéry giscard d'estaing
avait souhaité depuis des mois difficile
dans ces conditions d'avoir les succès
modeste
l'udf était rassemblée autour d'un
projet que pour beaucoup qui apparaît
pour beaucoup comme un peu inespéré
l'issue des débats qu'il ya eu dans ce
pays sur le rhin l'issue du notamment du
référendum
pourtant côté rpr on est aussi très
content et on met plutôt en avant
l'intégration progressive de l'europe
centrale et orientale et le contrôle
accru des gouvernements sur le conseil
européen et d'aldous sur le texte et pas
de regrets sur le débat à 12 mois des
présidentielles il était bien dangereux
ce texte était le meilleur
certains même parmi les plus sceptiques
pouvait attendre
reste à savoir qui mènera la liste
commune le p r jean françois deniau et
favori le cds dominique baudis outsider
eluard pire déjà presque convaincu de
s'effacer pour la troisième fois
consécutive réponse après les élections
cantonales avec une tête en tivement
véronique centlivre c'est votre rôle
qu'on peut lire dans ce texte commun que
nous cherchons pas triompher les chats
sont pas dire c'est notre rôle
vous savez quel était notre démarche
d'abord pour les français il se dit
c'est pas très important cette histoire
en ahl chômage on a des élections
nationales au fond le son open qu'est ce
que c'est c'est quand même important
parce que c'est une élection pour cinq
ans on va élire 87 députés français
revient quand un peu le nombre
et si ses députés sont influents au
parlement européen et beaucoup de sujets
l'agriculture de concurrence
environnement sur lesquels ils auront
leurs moyens
qu'est ce que nous voulions nous
voulions un projet commun et ce qu'a dit
votre journaliste tu as fait justement à
l'instant c'est que nous avons abouti à
ce projet comme un projet européen de
l'unef et du ap ap compris par le
téléspectateur est ce que c'est l'esprit
de maastricht dans ce projet comme ça va
plus loin
ça va plus loin c'est à dire c'est un
projet pour cinq ans les cinq ans dire
qu'est ce qu'il ya d'important là dedans
il ya d'abord vous rappeler que nous
l'avions dit il faut trois choses il
faut aller siéger dans le même groupe et
nos partenaires du lapeyre ont accepté
de venir siéger dans le même groupe que
nous c'est ce qu'on appelle le ppe le
parti populaire européen qui représente
le centre droit européen par exemple la
cd ou en allemagne la démocratie
chrétienne
en italie le parti populaire en espagne
nous seront tous ensemble dans le même
groupe
donc la france pèsera plus lourd dans le
futur parlement européen
deuxième chose nous voulions la monnaie
européenne avant la fin du chien est
alors ça comme vous le dites c'est la
sphère de maastricht et on confirme
qu'on respectera les engagements et le
calendrier de l'union économique et
monétaire c'est à dire pour les français
la monnaie avant 1990 alors ma question
avait un sens si j'ai cité l'esprit de
masse triste parce que je pense aux
élections quelles études précédemment à
ce que vous ne craignez pas un
repliement des français justement à
cause de la crise et donc un vote non
pas contre vous contre votre liste
commune mais comme une différence
il faudra faire campagne actuellement je
rassure on cherche à bien bien alors que
l'état d'esprit des français sur
l'europe
ils savent que l'europe est nécessaire
ils savent que pas de chance de s'en
sortir sont l'europe et par contre il
n'aime pas la manière dont on fait
l'europe
je crois qu'il faut leur dire en effet
on peut pas s'en sortir sans l'europe
quand on allait ce qui va se passer dans
le monde avec le problème de la russie
avec l'immense chine avec l'union qui se
fait en amérique du nord
bon on va pas avoir quinze pays à côté
les uns des autres qui n'ont pas
d'organisation commune donc on peut pas
s'en sortir sans l'europe
par contre il n'aime pas la manière dont
on fait l'europe parce qu'ils la
trouvent trop centralisée trop
bureaucratique trop loin d'eux est donc
dans notre projet nous essayons de
répondre à ces critiques nous parler
comme une future tête de liste de sept
noms sur une future tête de friches de
fès devant bousquet soul serait non j'ai
été et est de 10 de la dernière fois
j'ai fait d'ailleurs avec passion on
veut dire j'étais heureux de participer
à cette campagne
j'ai été élu roi
dernier on ne pas se présenter
successivement aux élections nationales
et européennes ça la partie sans essai
clinique
alors ce sera une liste unique donc
commune de l'udf et du rpr moitié-moitié
jusque là la règle d'abord adopter la
fois dernière fille la conduira alors
peut-être un mot sur comment elle sera
composée doublé je crois qu'il faut
d'abord qu'il y ait beaucoup de femmes
pas du tout système gadgets les rivages
emarcy hier non violent pour le to call
hurle canal tournis coeur battant
l'alter jeudi reste un peu injurieux
pour les femmes des traités ainsi en
traitement pour humains des quotas
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
on leur donne leur place le pass qui
leur revient et donc j'espère que nous
aurons sur notre lycée vers leur père
est d'accord beaucoup de femmes alors la
première place alors la première place
nous demanderons que ce soit un
quelqu'un de l'unef pourquoi c'est pas à
tout prix la première place et vos deux
raisons premières régions tout le monde
connaît l'attachement de l'udf à la
cause de l'europe la coupe d'europe
était largement défendue par l'udf au
cours de notre histoire politique et
ensuite nous avons de bons candidats
mais cette de l'alternance voudrait que
ce soit en interne l'opa de principe
absolu dans ce domaine pour les
différentes fonctions de l'état je crois
que là il ya une culture européenne de
l'udf que tout le monde connaît et puis
nous avons de bons candidats parce que
vous avez une hormis comme condition
qu'il fallait que la tête de liste à y
siéger
donc ça ne peut pas être quelqu'un de
grande qualité mais qui exerce
actuellement une autre fonction et nous
avons deux candidats déclarés à l'heure
actuelle qui sont jean françois deniau
qui est président du conseil général du
cher aideront dominique baudis qui est
le maire udf de toulouse et ils
représentent deux personnalités fortes
de talent entre lesquels l'udf à faire
son choix en votant puisque c'est la
façon démocratique de le faire au sein
du bureau politique de l'uc mais le rpr
accepte l'idée le principe d'une tête de
liste udf et côté rhénan pas a répondu
formellement je ne veux pas brusquer les
choses nous leur avons dit que nous
avions l'intention de demander cette
tête de jc je crois que nos partenaires
sont prêts en tout cas sont très ouverts
en tout cas sur ce sujet ne
craignez-vous pas à ces élections du 12
juin détournement dedans
jeu de cette élection comme on dit que
les français votent davantage sur la
situation économique et sociale du pays
plutôt que sur l'europe ça se produit
toujours on a toujours eu ça à préserver
à maastricht s'ils ont voté en partie
contre l'europe à eau sur en partie
contre le pouvoir socialiste de l'époque
puis contre la crise donc c'est naturel
dans une élection d'interroger quelqu'un
vous lui dites que vous votez mais lui
vote en fonction de ce qui sent à ce
moment là et s'il est malheureux ou s'il
était angoissé alors je crois que
naturellement il y aura cet aspect des
choses mais il est quand même important
de le dire aux français ceci n'est ce
pas le parlement européen qu'on va eelv
a siégé de 1994 1999
c'est donc le parlement européen doit
faire rentrer l'europe dans le prochain
siècle non prochain millénaire qu'est
l'europe une europe en miettes une
érosion se battront nom qui sera prête
par contre pour le progrès économique et
social or je crois que c'est important
et donc de long leur expliquer pourquoi
il faut mieux organiser l'europe et en
même temps comment il faut en europe
défendre les intérêts de la france si je
suis bien votre logique unitaire au sein
de la majorité liste unique sur l'europe
est ce que ça veut dire candidat commun
à l'élection présidentielle de 95
ça devrait vous le redire les élections
sont différents je pense vous parlez de
l'élection présidentielle soit qu'ils ne
signent pas s'ils ont fui les questions
vous réponds question mais nous avons
des élections départementales dans moins
de 15 jours son départ devant les
actions pour l'euro pour moi tu es puis
nous avons les actions pour la france
1995 donc dans plus d'un an nahl temps
d'en parler
simplement il faut bien voir que c'est
pas les mêmes les mêmes élections là on
vote c'est un seul tour une liste
nationale vous qui les gens doivent
aller siéger au même endroit ensemble il
est naturel qu'ils se présentent en
chambre d'autres élections sont des
élections de tous dans lesquels ont dit
on vous offre un choix et ensuite vous
décidez donc je n'ai pas la même logique
deux candidats merci monsieur le
président je voudrais que vous restez
avec nous parce que nous allons parler
d'une situation d'actualité ce qui se
passe dans le var il n'y a eu aucune
nouvelle audition aujourd'hui les six
personnes entendues hier sur
l'assassinât du député udf il ya nokia
ont été remises en liberté mais les
enquêteurs continuent de s'intéresser
aux relations entre la politique et
l'argent et cela donne de ce département
une image caricaturale que les varois de
souche ou d'adoption rouge
est lankais de michèle fines et agnès
vahramian les éditoriaux de la presse
locale avait ce matin des accents très
dur
à côté des photos des hommes politiques
var-matin s'interroge où et quand cela
va-t-il s'arrêter cette question armand
lacroix se les poser cet ancien
combattant retraité de la police a écrit
au journal pour exprimer ses doutes son
article parle des hommes politiques sans
les citer il semble apparemment que
certains et des relations douteuses je
ne dis pas qu'ils soient eux-mêmes
malhonnête et je trouve comme jeux
olympiques qu'il est absolument
détestable qu'un homme politique
ils se permettent d'avoir des relations
avec des voyous avec détruire c'est
absolument inacceptable
bon moi citoyen je ne l'acceptent pas à
hier les commentaires sont souvent plus
fataliste la classe politique locale
montrait du doigt c'est chaque jour un
peu plus grave au rugby club andré véran
entraîne une centaine d'enfants chaque
mercredi le sport ses valeurs son
énergie voilà ce qu'andré revendique lui
qui vite à la fois très près et très
loin de la violence et des affaires
comme tous on écoute tout ce qui se
passe au lit les journaux et à la
télévision mais derrière nous notre
monde du sport il était beau il est
pouvoir pour eros banques
ça nous fait que nous gardons un bon
moral mais dans ce monde là bas j'en
connais pas grand chose pour ne pas dire
aurier il est vrai que que c'est pas
beau de jour de nuit
si vous avez besoin de moi je suis à
votre entière disposition gros baiser
dans son bureau du conseil général
maurice à rex affiche une sérénité de
façade et cantonales sont dont dix jours
et si le président aimé quelques doutes
sur ses chances il sera candidat dans le
6e canton savez il n'y a pas de vague
qui leva yens et qu'ils ne reviennent
je suis persuadé que en tout cas toutes
les misères comme à fait me permettront
de limiter en quelque sorte la casse je
le pense très sincèrement en tout cas
rendez vous le 20 hockey
vous êtes le président de l'udf on a
l'impression que le poison est toujours
là ce soupçon qui pèse sur sur la
politique et l'argent pour moi je vous
donne mon sentiment là je le barça beau
département et est connu dans le monde
la côte varoise que l'on ne connaisse à
la côte d'azur il faut débarrasser le
var de ces pratiques
c'est pratique c'est à dire la collusion
dans le jour où elles existent entre la
politique et l'argent entre la politique
et le milieu faut débarrasser le var de
tout cela et il faut s'appuyer sur qui
pour le faire sur la justice sur la
police et sur l'opinion publique parce
que je suis allé aux obsèques
diane pyatt et j'y suis allé parce que
c'était une femme assassinée la première
femme assassinée député de l'histoire de
france
l'opinion qui étaient là les gens que
j'ai vus au cours de ces obsèques mans
toulouse il faut mettre fin à cette
situation
je demande donc au gouvernement je suis
sûr qu'il fera le nécessaire il faut
débarrasser le bar de ces pratiques et
je le demande au gouvernement et je
ferai tout ce qui sera fait dans ce sens
merci monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
le massacre d'hébron est due en partie à
la défaillance des services de sécurité
c'est ce que la commission d' enquête
israélienne a constaté en se rendant sur
place au caveau des patriarches charles
enderlin
aucun journaliste n'a pu suivre les
juges au delà de cette porte dans la
mosquée d'ibrahim l'armée en interdit
l'accès à la presse depuis le mas 1 la
commission denquête la pu inspecter
toutes les entrées de ce lieu saint en
compagnie des chefs militaires
deux cents soldats et policiers assurent
la sécurité partout les taches de sang
étaient nettoyés les quelques traces de
balles sur ce plafond de l'entrée
effacés mais pas celle ci voici les
caméras du circuit intérieur de
télévision qui ne fonctionne pas devant
le caveau des patriarches des habitants
viennent à la rencontre des journalistes
en dépit du couvre feu quand les colons
sont venus fêter pourim la veille il y
avait 300 soldats pour les garder mais
le matin du massacre
ils n'étaient que trois je ne crois pas
en cette commission des juifs qui
enquêtent sur des juifs
il n'en sortira rien des collants aussi
en réaliser qu'il se passe quelque chose
au caveau des patriarches
ils viennent de nouvelles
et voici ce que cela donne donc je
croise les dix jours meilleurs et jours
meilleurs c'est pas le gouvernement qui
va me donner moi je crois plus au
gouvernement
je ne crois pas je ne crois aucun angle
parce que tout est pour m durand main de
dieu le gouvernement décide de vous
évacuer d'ici le messie l'armée vient et
vous dites partir qu'est ce qu'on fait
je reste les colons et les militaires
sont les seuls à pouvoir se déplacer
dans la ville qui est sous couvre sept
morts et six blessés pour une amende de
300 francs cela s'est passé à reus
kirchen en allemagne un homme furieux
d'avoir été ainsi sanctionnée par un
juge est revenu peu après dans le
tribunal avec une bombe et un pistolet
patrice wendell sept morts sept blessés
parce qu'il arrive qu'un homme prenne
une arme et règle ses comptes avec ceux
qu'il considère comme ses ennemis
celui ci avait 39 ans peu avant 13
heures il comparaît dans l' annexe du
tribunal de ski à sean pour une affaire
de coups et blessures sur son ancienne
petite amie
en appel les juges confirment la
condamnation 7200 marque 25 mille francs
d'amendé
quelques a juré l'homme s'éclipse il
réapparaît une arme au poing
d'abord le président du tribunal une
balle dans le cou ensuite il sort une
bombe d'un sac et la jette devant lui le
souffle de l'explosion projette des
corps sur le trottoir dehors les
passants s'accroupissent sous une pluie
de débris de dans la salle d'audience
est ravagé parmi les victimes
l'ancienne petite amie du meurtrier dont
on ne connaîtra jamais le mobile il est
mort on dit de lui qu'il était d'humeur
sombre ce matin et qu'il avait refusé de
s'exprimer durant l'audience
on dit aussi que son avocat exaspéré
avait renoncé à défendre les personnes
personne n'avait deviner ses intentions
jacques perron s'intéressait de très
près au passé de sa belle-mère cette
curiosité lui at elle coûté la vie
c'était la question posée aujourd'hui au
procès de marie elisabeth consacré
d'avoir fait tuer l'ancien avocat
caroline laudun
jacques perron l'avocat a voulu jouer
les détectives huit ans après sa mort on
ne connaît toujours pas l'étendue des
découvertes
il s'était certes intéressé à
l'existence d'un beau père qu'ils
croyaient mort mais il avait surtout
fouiller dans le passé professionnel de
marc elisabeth cause son enquête s'était
intensifiée durant l'été 85 quelques
mois avant sa mort
ils voulaient en savoir plus sur
l'origine de la fortune de sa belle-mère
et connaître les raisons de sa radiation
comme avocate du barreau de paris à
trois reprises jacques perron avait
rencontré le bâtonnier d'année c'est par
lui qu'il avait appris les raisons de la
radiation en 81
une affaire qui avait fait grand bruit à
l'époque vous savez quand même trente
ans que je vais dans cette maison c'est
la première fois que l'on voit une
radiation pour des motifs pareil c'est
étonnant ah oui surtout que sous les
mois le dos et je les ai vus c'était
étonnant de la manière dont cet effet
mais expliquer à ses terres
formidablement bien fait mais les
investigations de jacques perron ne
s'arrête pas là son enquête l'avait mené
juste avant sa mort du côté des banques
suisses
manifestement il était inquiet il m'a
dit j'ai j'ai mis les pieds dans une
affaire dans laquelle va mieux je ne me
mêle pas il faut absolument lever le
voile
alors qu'il est toujours question de
l'origine inexpliquée de la fortune de
madame conce le président lui rappelle
ses propos en début de procès vous avez
dit une chose terrible dit-il si jacques
à des connaissances des comptes à
numéros en suisse c'était très dangereux
la mort d'un grand acteur qui
s'entendaient si bien avec bunuel et qui
a incarné si bien le charme discret de
la bourgeoisie fernando rey l'acteur
espagnol qui savait être aussi don
quichotte est décédé au volant vers
madrid
il avait 77 ans avec les biopics je vous
le disais au tout début de ce journal
l'instit revient sur france 2 ce soir à
20h50 plastique voulez mais vous êtes
très nombreux à le regarder vous allez
l'être aussi ce soir rebond soir gérard
klein bonsoir à nouveau je suis pas mort
le parti moi je suis là s'habiller
pareil tout à l'heure j'ai vu j'ai vu
baisse de la stib chemise de lin site et
on va le voir dans l'extrait en vain
semble aller il n'y a aucune raison pour
que vous preniez cet argent gelé des
douaniers de charité ni pitié gaver de
cet argent les enfants ont invité leurs
trois copains je suis dit mais je veux
pas me croire je crois pas crois tu
étais tu comme sa peinture la note 'aaa'
chambre mathieu s'il te plaît pourquoi
j'ai retrouvé ma tu es en train de
pleurer qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça
c'est pas moi de le dire
écoutez vous êtes quand même responsable
de ces enfants nous qui vous essayer de
protéger huit mois qu'est ce qu'il a
appris qu'on m'a vu un train de voler
c'est ça oui c'est vrai j'ai volé vous
savez ce que c'est vous d'avoir un
enfant de ne pas pouvoir lui donner à
manger savez je fais tout ce que je peux
pour qu'ils aient une vie d'enfant comme
les autres enfin les des choses que je
suis obligé lui dire
en effet je voulais pas qu'ils
l'apprennent ça va peut-être été mieux
qu'ils ne sachent pas oui mais allez
savoir
en tout cas ne l'empêché pas de se faire
inviter ça s'appelle la solidarité
c'est une fiction c'est le fils d'une
maman qui est au chômage mais c'est une
fiction j'allais dire quotidienne
souvent dans le pays oui malheureusement
en ce moment les solidarités enfin novak
parle de solidarité tout le monde parle
de solidarité j'ai entendu monsieur
chirac l'autre jour qui parlait de
solidarité morale et justice est en fait
c'est exactement l'instit est donc
l'histoire ce soir c'est la relation
entre les enfants de ceux qui ont du
travail et les enfants de ceux qui n'ont
pas de travail
voilà c'est à dire les latitudes dans
nos sociétés les gens ont une attitude
qui est déclenchée par leur appartenance
à une une caste sociale enfin une
position dans la société
c'est vrai qu'elle est pauvres les
riches ce qui frappe le plus c'est la
distance souvent que mettent les gens
quand quand quand il s'adresse aux
autres et c'est vrai que si vous
n'entendez hommes politiques parlent et
parfois on a l'impression tout de même
que ces gens là 10e marché avec moi mais
attendez vous restez pas à côté vous
aller un peu plus loin
en revanche dans l'andante dans cette
fiction dans cette série de l'institut a
pas de distance entre les gens qui la
regarde et les enfants auxquels
s'adresse victor novak et les gens donc
dans cet épisode là effectivement on
parle de des enfants de chômeurs d'un
enfant d'une chômeuse quoi et puis d'un
enfant nantis entre guillemets c'est à
dire sa maman a de l'argent le père a de
l'argent aussi
et c'est vrai que les attitudes sont
complètement différentes le succès
considérable de l'instit notamment en
termes d'audience et puis d'image c'est
bon c'est vous bien sûr je suis
extrêmement nettes oui oui je suis très
beau mais c'est aussi parce que c'est si
j'ose dire c'est nous c'est notre vie
c'est la vie du pays et que les français
en regardant l'instit se retrouvent
voilà un film c'était la bonne idée de
pierre grimblat en bon une bonne idée de
pierre qu'ils voulaient faire une
télévision enfin ils disaient qu'ils
servent un peu quelque chose c'est vrai
dans dans les enfants tout le monde
retrouve sa propre enfance bien entendu
dans les décors dans lesquels on tourne
les français qui regardent la télévision
parce que ici on est à paris mais il ya
beaucoup d'autres gens qui ne se passait
pas par avoir lu mon savoir et votre
savoir voilà on a tourné au made who
tous ces gens là vivent dans des décors
dans des paysages magnifiques
donc je pense enfin mais je pense pas
beaucoup j'ai vite c'est pour ça que
j'essaie de rester modeste
la série marche bien parce que les gens
retrouvent leur enfance et puis et puis
la france quoi des beaux paysages en
tournée avec de petits comédiens des
jeunes comédiens oui avec des enfants
des enfants et comment comment vous les
percevez bon il tourne remarquablement
bien avec vous très juste mais par
rapport justement à cette vie sociale
qu'est la nôtre est ce que vous les
sentez attentifs ils ont 10 ans est ce
que vous les sentez attentif à l'air du
temps
oui parce que quand on arrive sur sur un
tournage et unac les inquiétudes chez
des enfants bien entendu qui est partagé
par leurs parents puisque le premier
jour les parents viennent avec le petit
ygos par la main exactement comme une
rentrée donc il ya une inquiétude mais
au travers leur attitude bien entendu
moi ça m'intéresse je ressens tout de
suite lequel est inquiet parce qu'il n'a
jamais tourné
et puis on voit tout de suite si les
parents s'entendent bien si les parents
sont divorcés aussi les parents sans
gueule ça se voit tout de suite
tout de suite on peut pas truqué on peut
pas cacher la vérité excellents
comédiens vous savez que vous feriez un
excellent commentateur de phase 2 de
notre chronique quotidienne c'est très
intimidant
maintenant on vous dit j'ai tellement
juste non non j'écoute sébastien gras et
on vous écoute ce soir on regarde ce
soir merci gérard moulin à tout à
l'heure
ces dernières années le grunge
d'ailleurs que vous devez connaître
était à la mode les avions étaient fort
prisé mais les stylistes comme leurs
clientes ont compris qu'il y avait
quelques impudence à passer pour pauvres
quand on ne l'est pas alors les
stylistes comme leur cliente reviennent
tout naturel marie-josée les picards et
bernard connor ont vu défiler saint
laurent et givenchy
la leçon jeannette les mannequins qui
présente la collection yves saint
laurent des étudiantes chic décontracté
fantaisiste du pantalon gris au kilt du
cardigan canaris obérer le velours au
grand chapeau ou costume de garçons elle
et c'est la mode dans tous ses états
mais si jeune elles savent déjà porté le
classique tailleur noir des grandes
occasions
les clients de givenchy sont plus
adultes les ados 6ème une mode bien
construites très soigné très
circonstancielle les tailleurs
impeccables des alliances de couleurs
qu'il doit rien au hasard
ensemble les collections de prêt à
porter des grands couturiers n'ont pas
succombé à la morosité de la crise ni à
l'hypocrisie du misérabilisme le drudge
acclamé la saison passée semble avoir
fait long feu
c'est pas appelé à une grande une grande
histoire quand même le rush était quand
même un épiphénomène pour moi comme lady
france l'acia sagnac une des directrices
de boutiques les plus éclairés de paris
il est temps de revenir à une mode sans
ostentation mais correspondant cours
chacune a son mode de vie
nous avons commencé ce journal par la
violence à garges les gonesse dans le
val-d'oise près de paris
nous allons conclure ce journal par la
violence à garges-lès-gonesse de
nouveaux incidents
on semble se sont semble-t-il produits
philippe bouaziz est en direct de garges
et bien paul où il semble que l'appel au
calme lancé tout à l'heure par la
famille de la victime et par le maire
n'ait pas été entendu par tout le monde
environ 200 jeunes se sont rassemblés il
était en gros 19h30
il ya eu quelques jets de pétards de
fusée les crs se sont mis en position et
puis tout est retenu assez calme une
voiture de nos confrères de la trois a
été renversé mais surtout une voiture de
policiers a été pris dans une embuscade
un camion leur a barré la route la
voiture a été assez sérieusement défoncé
mais surtout des policiers ont également
été prises à partie l'un d'entre eux est
relativement sonné à l'heure qu'il est
que va-t-il se passer maintenant on ne
peut pas tellement savoir il semble que
l'attention soit assez forte mais
va-t-on connaître comme la nuit
précédente des incidents sérieux
rien ne permet de le dire pour l'instant
en tout cas un fort dispositif policier
est en place en ce moment à garges
merci philippe eu cette violence a
éclaté à la suite de l'assassinât d'un
jeune qui aurait été tué par d'autres
jeunes et à suite d'un malentendu entre
policiers et les jeunes de cette cité de
la banlieue parisienne violences
également grande bretagne je vous le
dise au cours de ce journal cinq obus de
mortier je dis bien de mortier ont été
tirés près de l'aéroport de heathrow à
londres
il n'y aurait pas de victime l'attentât
n'a pas été revendiqué mais évidemment
les engrais plantes bien sûr à lire à
philippe le fait reviendra sur cet
attentat
en grande bretagne et sur les incidents
qui ont éclaté ce soir à
garges-lès-gonesse à 23h20 après last
hit à 20h50 avec gérard klein et après
la météo de sophie davant en quelques
instants et évidemment après les courses
demain gérard leclerc à 7h50 et à 13
heures daniel bilalian adema batteur
bonsoir